I learned two things this week one that
Kevin Bacon is hilarious and two that
Kevin Bacon is a Swifty I did not know
this what's a Swifty
hi
hi
everybody agrees uh Taylor Swift fan oh
I didn't know what a Swifty was oh yeah
no I love Taylor oh my gosh yeah Sophie
wanted to do one of the songs and I
thought that one had that great kind of
beat and uh so we had fun doing that a
Great Hero
named Kevin Beacon
teaches an entire city full of people
with sticks up their butts that dancing
wow
it's the greatest thing there is you
were name dropped in the very first
Guardians film a couple times what was
your reaction to that I fell off my
chair because I went to the theater
opening weekend you know having worked
with James Gunn but we hadn't been in
touch and he never warned me that this
was coming if there was no I had no idea
and I sat there and all of a sudden
they're you know talking about me my jaw
just dropped that I just was like I'm
looking around to the people in the in
the theater are you hearing what I'm
hearing you know that's me and I call my
wife afterwards and said I want you to
come see this Guardians of the Galaxy
movie with me I want to see it again
you're gonna love the movie and I'm not
gonna tell you but there's a surprise of
it so I was thrilled when they circled
back around many years later clearly and
I had this idea for the Christmas
special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon
you come with us as a Christmas present
it's great are you kidding I mean
these movies are so much a part of the
fabric of entertainment and the
entertainment history and not only the
movies you know the the comic books the
whole world when we were shooting it you
know to walk onto that set and to see
this kind of beautiful machine that's is
making these things was really exciting
you know they were in the middle of
shooting Guardians three I guess and
then just kind of carved out some time
in the middle of it to do the special so
I got to really see how the whole thing
works and and uh it was it was amazing
and this is your second Marvel role
technically did it bring back any X-Men
memories yeah it is technically my
second Marvel role that's right that's
the other one you know the you know yeah
disconnected but still Marvel it's hard
to keep up the work that I do normally
is not in a in fantasy you know what I
mean it's it's I I do things that are
tend to be more realistic and grittier
and darker
you know to be in that kind of world is
is is just unusual for me in the course
of my career you know so it's a it's a
lot of fun some people have really spent
a lot of time you know working in those
kinds of situations but I really haven't
and to see it happen in the effects and
the you know all that kind of stuff is
really exciting did it spark anything in
you are you like okay wait now I
actually kind of do one
listen I would I would love to I mean it
was great to be part of X-Men and I
liked the characters that you know they
kind of created for me and that I was
kind of part of you know creating so you
know whichever Universe it is and
whether I end up just playing me I I
would love to come back at any time how
does one prepare to play themselves
research years of research you know 60
I've been researching this role for 64
years now it's like one big long ride
along
right you know listen the funny thing is
is that I love this kind of heightened
idea of what my life is and what like
for instance the house that I have I can
guarantee you that my house doesn't look
anything like that house so it's kind of
fun that it's like a fantasy sort of
version of what my life might be you
know I've done quite a few things where
I've played myself both in films but
also in you know commercial spots and
stuff like that and I take my work
really really seriously but I don't take
myself really really seriously so to be
able to poke fun at yourself and you
know be terrified of aliens and you know
all those kinds of things it's just a
blast
[Music]
foreign